foreign
guys are you getting inspired today with
all the wonderful talks
welcome to Stanford
all right let me start by asking you
guys a question have you ever heard
someone having an idea
and you said hmm that's a great solution
to a problem
you should go and convert that into a
business have you heard that
I see a lot of you guys nodding here
and that's normal because
ideas are inspiring
they're exciting we just know when
something and someone is on to something
now tell me that time when you actually
saw one of those great ideas converted
into actual business
and a very successful one
very less nodding year
and that's also normal because
best ideas are always not the ones that
stick or take off
actually it's a very unique combination
of what we do which actually makes ideas
take off
I would say that making great ideas take
is actually less unicorn and More in our
own individual power
and often startups find it very hard to
find that combination
as many of you know that I am a
co-founder of Lisa which is a Sanford
GSP lead incubator and accelerator
and we have had the pleasure of working
with hundreds of ideas startup ideas
from within this community along with a
lot of mentors and supporters from this
community
and in doing so I have also seen a lot
of realities and hardships
of these Founders in getting these ideas
adopted
even though the ideas had great
potential to succeed
and that's what I'm here to talk to you
guys about today
over the last two years I have sought to
understand what is it that makes those
great ideas stick and what makes them
fail at the same time I've also
interviewed industry luminaries VCS
startups
journalists you name it
and I've come to the conclusion that it
is often things that are more in our own
power knowing where to start and how to
influence this which is more important
than I actually the business models and
the strategy canvases and all those
things that we work on which is of
course important I'm not saying that's
not important
so in the next six minutes I'm going to
take you through six elements of what
makes a great idea stick
number one here
oh it's on the other side
um
most of us are familiar with this one
right
um it's the drive the hunger the vision
an entrepreneur has
and uh it goes back to my first question
to you guys that how many have actually
seen
some great ideas that have actually
passed the wooden it'd be nice face
it starts with this moment
when actually an idea holder has that
unwavering commitment to make that idea
into a business or convert it into
something big
stories I think we've heard about some
great stories today as well and we know
that stories help us connect
and they also help us connect with other
people and other people to our own ideas
so um I would like to I would like you
to guys to think about advertising
campaigns for instance Nike that does
that really well
so let's focus again
and have you heard of the Marlboro Man
here
this for for many times for for a long
time actually Marlboro tried to convince
us that freedom lifestyle is synonymous
to smoking and we believed that although
it's while the outdated at this point in
time but at this point in time we did
believe that and this shows the power of
story and power of getting into the
heads and the aspirations of the
consumers even before you actually
create an idea
so I would say stories telling stories
starts much earlier than actually what
you think even before the product is
even conceived
the third Point here has to do with
engaging your customer in building your
brand which really means how can you
actually make
your customers part of shaping your idea
Lego is a brand that does this really
well uh Lego has an ideations Community
where actually even in the times of too
much screen time they're really doing
well that's because they give
opportunity to customers to actually
take part in aviation process as well as
um through sharing feedback contests
just be part of what they need next and
that's what Lego does really well and
this is what is known as Ikea effect the
ik effect is a is a study that was done
in 2011 which says that people often
tend to buy ideas or have bias towards
ideas that are built by them and this is
also something which we also use in
negotiations most of the times the ik
effect
filling in structural holes I've taken
that from Power class of of Professor
fever but it actually holds true also
for entrepreneurship
let me explain that for those of you do
not know that
so let's say in a in an ecosystem there
is group a and Group B they both have
resources and needs
it would make sense for them to actually
share those resources right
there's a hole here
which means that they either are not
aware of these communities being in the
same ecosystem or they do not know or
have a platform to do that
but what if we built a bridge here
now this would enable sorry
this would enable
um
people to actually share the resources
and the capabilities
and this is what we know in
entrepreneurship often as platforms like
Etsy for buyers and sellers or Airbnb
for
hosts and guests
the fifth Point here and those of you
who know me well you know how much I
believe in the power of community
so leaning into collective intelligence
of community is what a lot of the brands
and a lot of people do to actually make
their ideas grow and stick
what it does is that you would also able
to
help self-mobilize people to initiate
you know activities based on your ideas
and that's how it grows it also creates
um ownership
as well as
um you know it also creates ownership
and also agency to actually take your
idea forward and you are not the only
one who's actually fighting to get that
idea to multiple people
um as an example you see a lot of
networking organizations like
information which is the founder is
Deepa
she started she wanted to actually have
more women of color in leadership roles
so she started with a
dinner of 12 people to exchange ideas
and they loved it
um so what she did she basically
empowered the rest of the group to
actually start doing more activities and
now they have a wait list of thousand
plus people wanting to build that
community and have those networking and
events
the sixth Point here is do with allyship
and I want to bring your attention to
this allyship here it is also very
important for bringing diversity into
entrepreneurship that is something which
is very close to my heart
it is bringing together individuals and
entrepreneurs sorry individuals and
organizations to help build the idea
and also create mechanisms and
institutions that is difficult to ignore
what you want to do
code I hope you guys have heard of her
of reshma sajani who started this this
initiative what she did was she
basically connected with leaders
organizations especially interest groups
to connect
her idea through mentorships and
internships as well as through various
other initiatives
to create an Allied Power to create this
idea and actually go beyond go beyond
just what was in her own head or what
was there in her own organization's head
at that point in time so creating Allied
Power is also something which actually
helps you create momentum through
allyship and it's something which is in
all of our power to do that very easily
so these are the six points
um which I I have discovered that these
are the six points which actually help a
great idea stake but if there's one
thing I want you guys to take away from
this talk here
and I think it's an easy conclusion to
draw it is that ideas stick
when it becomes a movement
studies show that 25 percent of people
are actually needed or minimum for 25
people are needed to create
um you know to create a sort of momentum
for an idea which actually then picks up
adoption
so when you are thinking about an idea
that you want to work as an entrepreneur
or if you are somebody who wants to
facilitate a change all you have to
think about is how can I convert my idea
into a movement
and at the same time how can I what
strategy can I use to get at least 25
percent of the people who need to be
reached to be part of that movement
so in doing so whenever you do that I
hope you will remember these six points
and you will think about your idea not
as an idea but how can I make this great
idea into a movement
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]